the rise of the ufc has been historic in
20 years it's gone from an outlier on
the world stage to an integral part of
espn's future business and it's still
growing behind it all has been one man
dana white his stated ambition is to
turn ufc into the biggest sport in the
world and he's as big of a character as
you can find shut them up
scumbag
quick takes chief correspondent jason
kelly recently sat down with dana in las
vegas to understand his plan for global
domination i'm meeting jason at bar fly
in new york to hear more
[Music]
so jason i have watched a ufc fight
before i would not call myself a ufc fan
but it's massive and i didn't realize
that full confession like i wasn't a big
fan either i didn't know that much about
it like you i sort of see everything
through the lens of business i think
what's fascinating is increasingly if
you show up at a bar
on a fight night it's gonna be on all
these tvs and so
i kind of wanted to figure out what was
going on so here are the numbers they
buy this thing for two million dollars
in 2001. dana white yeah and a couple
brothers from las vegas the fertittas
today there are a couple estimates that
put the value of the ufc at 10
billion with a b 2 million to 10 billion
20 years
dana white this guy is somebody who is
very outspoken very public but he
doesn't do a lot of interviews he
doesn't do a lot certainly about the
business and so i did work my way into
sort of the inner sanctum and actually
got into dana white's office with him to
sort of break it down during fight week
it's two million bucks like i mean
and look what it's become the landscape
in the backyard is worth two million
dollars you know what i mean it's true
right it's crazy we bought the company
and this wasn't allowed on pay-per-view
porn
was on pay-per-view and you could pay
for it but you could not pay for the ufc
we bought the company and our goal was
to get it onto free tv
i mean one of the interesting things to
think about is
ufc started back in 2005 especially
having to pay to be on spike tv spike tv
no no shade despite tv but it's not espn
it's not the worldwide leader now
ufc is really the anchor of espn plus
the new streaming service and that week
in vegas and certainly every fight week
coming up
you cannot be on espn whether it's on tv
dot com on the mobile app without seeing
ufc so prominently and this is in many
ways this is what dana always envisioned
[Applause]
but some people passed on him so i'm
curious i was able to do that in 20
years sheer force of will
in many ways i mean this is a guy he's
kind of one of one in many ways there
are very few people who have
such a sort of ferocious and kind of so
themselves personality for better or
worse i mean he is a polarizing figure
in many ways there are a lot of people
who don't like his politics they don't
like the way that he sort of acts
publicly they don't agree with some of
the things he says
about the pandemic he's been very
dismissive of
kovid in many ways and sort of to the
extent that it was actually helpful to
the business sort of plowed through it
this was the first business
to come back you know the bottom line is
the the system worked a lot can be
learned by what we're doing here not
just for professional sports but you
know sending people back to work and
lots of other things in life
so it'll be interesting to see
now that
ufc is very mainstream in some ways like
how does he
maintain his dananess i love that
dananess and so unapologetically dana
yeah but
he's not just dana anymore right right i
mean he he can't be justine anymore he
can't
to some extent but one of the checks
that he has actually is
part of an i think one of the greatest
odd couples in sports business right now
arya manuel you probably remember him as
the basis of ari gold on the show
entourage get james cameron on the phone
get dana gordon on the phone
this is now the biggest agency in the
world
and i'm the head of it it would be ahri
an endeavor who would ultimately buy a
controlling stake in the ufc for four
billion dollars remember this was a
company that fertitus and dana bought
for 2 million
roughly 15 years earlier
and since then ari and endeavor have
been really instrumental in letting dana
be dana but also kind of helping it be
even more ambitious than it was before
[Music]
[Applause]
they're still facing a lot of
controversy though i mean anybody who
looks online will see that they have an
anti-trust suit against them i mean how
do they navigate that what's their plan
yeah this could be
probably one of the biggest obstacles
that's out there for them and it really
comes down to the idea that they're not
being fair with how much they pay their
fighters on our way over to uh
the courthouse now the athletes are paid
only about 20 of the total revenues of
the league compared with up to 50 that
you see in other professional leagues
ufc argues that they do pay their
fighters fairly they do take care of
them that fighter pay has increased 600
percent over the past few years and that
is commensurate with what they are doing
as a business you know normally in these
cases the executives you know they won't
comment they shut down dana takes it
straight on ari takes it straight on
everybody makes money here everybody
makes a good living and
there's enough money to reinvest back
into the sport yeah grow the sport and
grow the brand we're growing a real
business we're heading into this
this this country where everybody gets a
trophy and everybody should get this and
everybody should get that
when i leave
when i leave maybe it'll turn uh this
place will be left of the hyenas and
then come in and rip this thing apart
but as long as i'm here
yeah it ain't gonna happen
[Music]
so jason where does this ufc endeavor
partnership go from here well i mean i
think it's mutually beneficial
for both sides obviously in the sense
that endeavor now has
this model nice shot that it can
now show to wall street and say this is
what this company is gonna be when we
talk about the merging of talent and
entertainment and live sports and all
those different things like now we can
say we have the ufc this is what it
looks like so from the ufc's perspective
you know they've got this partner now
that is very willing and eager to take
them global and that's definitely where
dana is thinking and from his
perspective if they can survive 2020 not
only survive but thrive i'm gonna make
this shot
they can do anything
hey thanks for watching bloomberg quick
take now subscribe to our channel to see
the biggest stories the moment they
happen from around the world and tune in
to our 24 7 live stream for global news
coverage documentaries interviews deep
dives and shows on the stories that you
care most about
you